there are two possible ways to extend
your life with action that you take
today one is to do things that allow you
to maintain your health for a longer
period and the other is to act to hasten
this research so that the time when
therapies come along which can
rejuvenate you and give you another
lease of life come along in time for you
even if you are going downhill
those two things are additive so to
speak now independent criteria now it
turns out that the first criterion that
not much we can do unless of course you
are unusually susceptible to some
particular age-related problem like you
know some people come down with type 2
diabetes and their thirties there are
drugs for that if you are the sort of
normally healthy person whose natural
lifespan is going to be 80 or more then
there is nothing to speak of that we can
do that will extend your life by an
appreciable amount or at least that is
proven to have dance to be able to do so
so we have to look at number two
and number two the situation is
completely different it doesn't matter
who you are whether you're a scientist
or a broadcaster or a journalist or a
general member of the public it doesn't
matter who you are you can make a
difference by contributing to the
enthusiasm in society for this work by
changing the mood of society and thereby
changing the funding environment so the
work will be done more quickly
I personally for example don't get
enough sleep because I'm travelling all
the time I'm on the road I'm trying to
get this stuff to happen and from a
purely health point of view that's
probably bad for me it's probably
shortening my life but I'm pretty sure
that I'm bringing forward the day when
these therapies will arrive by a larger
amount that I'm shortening my life so
even in my own personal
and probably winning and of course I'm
not only doing it for selfish turns I'm
doing it to save your life as well
Oh